Họng thức kê lên của bản chương nhiều cửa trời rế xin nghiệm lắm tháng 8 trương sang,
hồi đâm hoá lý nước của đăng lưỡi mặt với những thức vầy tính và pháp,
và hưởng qua chức về sự li các cuộc sức độ của tế.
Các biểu tại bây đối đông như thế này,
có chỉ hiện nay của hội đồng án vẫn phải nánh chất tự thị dởi xong nămu nhìn chính trang bố mấy lâm,
không còn đại diện cho thị dở hiện tại,
và chứ theo kịp những thị đổi của bối cảnh toàn cầu.
Theo ông cửa trời rế xin,
các nước thường suynh sự dụng quên phụ quên khiến thức quan hình yulần không thể hành động cho các tình vũ khổng khoảng.
Điều này làm dễ lên những y vấn về khả nắng của hội đồng bỏa,
cho bình năng trạng các cuộc sức độ đăng đều thang.
Huy đứng đầu đến của đồng thời kêu gọi các bây linh quan tại Li Băng khiểm trế,
và nối lại các đủ lượng ngoại xa ông nhầm chấm rất giao trang,
ông cạnh báo tình yến đạo tại cú gia này đang sổ đi nhánh chống,
khi hàng chăm nghìn người bụt phải dời bỏ nhà cửa,
gió các cuộc thông tích bà giao trang.
Chào mọi kệnh này, lấy nguu đại phát động lời kêu gọi hội chợ thần cấp.
Chỉ giá, bác chăm trửa đưa lòng Mỹ nhằm giống người dân Li Băng,
ông phá vinh nữ hộ của sức độ đăng đồng dọng trong cuộc.